j'accueille amérique aux mafias d'
l hélico macias bonsoir bonsoir
enrico qui ne l'oublions pas ambassadeur
itinérant de l'onu un oui c'est bien
c'est bien payé mais non c'est à dire
c'est moi qui paye les voyages
alors d'accord alors sérieusement devant
la passivité des des russes et des
chinois devant l'indécision des
européens
on est à peu près sûr maintenant que
l'iran va avoir la la bombe atomique
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal vous
clients à la bombe atomique quand un
pays a la possibilité d'avoir la bombe
atomique
ça dépend quel usage en en fait si c'est
pour le positif ou pour lever les gatif
moi j'estime que avec les déclarations
du maigrichon président iranien pour ne
pas dire autre chose s'il a la bombe
atomique c'est très grave pour
l'humanité
et je suis sûr qu'ils en feraient un
usage néfastes et moi je voudrais quand
même élevé ma voix contre le fait que
l'iran possède la bombe atomique parce
que ça me rappelle des temps où le monde
était passif devant la montée du nazisme
et là je crois qu'il ya une un danger
réel et j'ai peur que le monde encore
refasse la même erreur et se disent
rohff
après tout c'est pas grave il ya
d'autres pays quand la bombe atomique
pourquoi un but l'iran n'aurait pas la
bombe atomique et pied et si ils avaient
la bombe atomique pour l'utiliser et
faire du mal
donc vous êtes pour une intervention
préventive american vaut déjà vous
mettez no 1 dans un mois que tu fasses
iam indien comme solution je suis à la
place de l'onu ouais j'appartiens à
l'onu ouais chemin l'onu notre rôle à
nous c'est quoi c'est de dire aux
américains
attention même si vous êtes la nation la
plus forte du monde c'est pas vous les
arbitres du monde larbitre c'est l'onu
c'est vrai c'est vrai donc c'est pas les
états unis qui vont avoir le droit de
faire une action préventive contre
l'iran
mais la communauté mondiale c'est à dire
tous les pays sous le couvert de l'onu
doivent demander aux nations les plus
fortes de s'interposer à l'iran le
problème entre causse et que ni les
russes ni les chinois ne veulent le
faire ça mais moi je le fais
il lèvera et fajr accords ont plu enrico
on a reçu ici récemment boutros boutros
ghali ancien général de l'oiv shimon
peres tous parlent en parlant d'israël
d'une colonie et qu'ils comparent israël
aujourd'hui à l'algérie française
je les adore nous transmettrons skalli
c'est un homme de paix c'est un homme
qui est contre la violence de dire
qu'israël est une colonie c'est un petit
peu c'est un petit peu exagéré
il faut quand même ça m'étonne de la
part de boutros boutros ghali qui parle
comme ça parce que ceux qui ne connaît
pas l'histoire
je suis désolé c'est ce qu'on appelle
israël était en palestine ce qu'organise
il y a il y à 2006 de milan c'est zéro à
côté de 30 ans alors 30 ans c'est quoi
côtés de dakota et demi le bret alors va
rester dans l'algérie ex française
quand georges frêche traite les harkis
de sous-hommes moi je trouve que c'est
scandaleux
je trouve que c'est scandaleux parce que
on n'a pas le droit de traiter des
hommes qui se sont battus pour la france
à l'époque parce que l'algérie n'était
pas encore indépendantes
l'algérie était était la france et ces
musulmans parce que la france est
plurielle c'est pas comme l'algérie
l'algérie n'est pas un pays plus rien là
maintenant mais à l'époque la france
étaient installées en algérie
il y avait des juifs des musulmans et
les chrétiens il y avait des musulmans
qui se sont battus pour la france à
l'époque donc sont pas des collabos
comment comment les reins de traîtres et
de collabo alors de dire que des gens
sont des sous-hommes
c'est du racisme j'appelle ça moi je dis
que georges frêche est un racisme et
vous savez qu'il n'a pas été viré du
parti socialiste ben
c'est incroyable moi personnellement il
est viré de mon coeur je vais pas
prendre la défense de georges frêche je
le connais même pas mais alors il faut
bien dire il ay là il
non mais il les a traités de sous-hommes
non pas parce qu'ils avaient ils étaient
du côté des français pendant la guerre
d'algérie mais simplement de ce qui
s'était couché devant de gaulle une fois
et que là ils allaient ils allaient
encore à vers la droite pactiser avec
eux c'est pour ça qu'ils haïssent
il s'en est d'ailleurs excusé après
droit de traiter de sous chiens les gens
qui ont des opinions différentes des
nôtres
ça sert haquin qui pense différemment de
moi je ne traite pas de sous-hommes ça
c'est vrai voilà c'est alors l'attitude
de bouteflika en ce moment qui refusent
le traité d'amitié avec la france et qui
accuse la france d'avoir perpétré un
génocide de l'identité algérienne
ça vous choque oui ça me choque parce
que je ne comprends pas qu'un chef
d'état conduisent les affaires de son
pays par le passé et non vers l'est vers
la lumière
ouais et moi je trouve que c'est on a
déjà payé 7 cette page de l'histoire
ok ils ont eu leur indépendance mais
pourquoi encore culpabiliser les
français de colonisation de revenir
toujours dessus ça y est se sont ils
sont retirés ils ont qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait en 90 pour les massacres qui a
eu en algérie
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait rien du tout
alors de traiter les français de deux
génocides d'identité je trouve que c'est
un peu exagéré du moment qu'ils ont
aimés pendant ce déjà vous pensez pas
comme lui donc que la france doit faire
acte de repentance sur la colonisation
la repentance c'est le résultat de
l'histoire
qu'est ce que c'est le résultat de
l'histoire l'algérie n'est plus
française elle est indépendante je
respecte l'algérie à l'irréel maintenant
est ce que vous pensez par exemple que
la france a tenu compte du drame qu'ont
été les massacres de sétif en algérie en
45 quand on a quand même tué
il est milliers des milliers d'algériens
il ne faut pas masquer
aucune vérité historique mais aussi il
faut que tout le monde alors et al sur
le papier tout ce qui a été fait et si
on veut la réconciliation il faut pas
sans arrêt revenir sur tout ce qui nous
a séparés
bon à part ça
vous êtes ici ce soir enrico pour un
nouvel album
c'est ce courage et parce qu'à votre âge
pourriez vous contenter de faire des
best-of
non c'est vrai nom c'est courageux non
c'est un kiff que je serai mes clients
mes chansons alors ça s'appelle la vie
populaire c'est écrit comme le précédent
par jean loup dabadie kent art mengo est
le premier single c'est ça
tantôt en volumes ont fondu
pour m
une prison
les pensions
si tu savais combien j'ai pris nos
distances
avec les faux amis que d'habitude est un
en mieux j'ai senti le point d'étape
présenté en signant
sur les cartes postales
si tu savais combien j'ai manqué plus de
chance
pour pour
oublier notre plein me fatale
combien j'ai donné ma peau
laissant petit
pour mieux j'ai passé des emprunts
justin
un réseau dacia serrement de coeur
extrait de son nouvel album la vie
populaire
enrico macias à l'olympia du frontier en
octobre au 5 novembre devrait rendre un
texte merveilleux mais voilà alors c'est
vrai que depuis orange amère l'album
précédent vous êtes revenu au style de
vos débuts il ya 45 ans et ça se passe
très bien les radars les gens adorent et
c'est beaucoup
l'idée de mon fils de me faire revenir à
mes racines musicales des vraies racines
musicales et avec son équipe on a fait
vraiment un disque dans la bonne humeur
d'une façon artisanale
tous les jours on enregistrait quand
vous voulez sympa quoi il est en 1938 ah
oui tu as à faire bientôt soixante dix à
ben oui dans deux ans et demi
incroyablement bien conservés a fait
quoi
je sais pas je fais un peu de sport je
fais attention à ce que je mange
ouais et puis je suis je suis heureux
dans ma tête c'est vrai pour ça aussi
que les gens vieillissent souvent parce
qu'ils sont malheureux où ils ont dû
stress et tout ça puis moi j'ai beaucoup
d'amour autour de moi ça me permet de
tenir le coup vous n'avez pas été
épargné quand même il ya eu le départ
d'algérie la mort de raymond la maladie
de votre femme etc
je ne serai pas été épargné par la vie
quand même nom mais je pense que l'amour
ma passion de la musique est une
thérapie extraordinaire dans tous ces
moments là dans tous ces mauvais moments
et l'amour du public sans aucune
démagogie je crois je crois que ça
propulse un homme n'importe qui même
même toit thierry barret j'ai découvert
ça c'était pas dans le spectacle qu'on
ya quelques années mais j'ai découvert
ça alors vous dites si aucune
coquetterie à propos de mon âge
les rites je vis avec façon c'est pas
tellement donc c'est plus facile et vous
dites je suis pas mûre pour le lifting
je suis pas contre ceux qui qui veulent
faire du des liftings si c'est
nécessaire
moi ce qui me concerne je voudrais
vieillir normalement quoi que ce soit un
bon vieux plutôt qu'un vieux beau